gracias por comunicarse la realidad que
la argentina ha quedado en un contexto
muy frágil después de la pandemia y en
consecuencia de la cuarentena la
argentina ya viene de 10 años de una
caída de su economía con altas altas y
con altas tasas de inflación y con como
bien plantea bajos con gran presión
tributaria las cuentas contables se
retiran no cierran en términos
económicos por más que hayamos arreglado
el tema de nuestra deuda todavía tenemos
cuentas pendientes que tenemos que
resolver para poder fomentar que las
pacientes se inviertan hoy estamos en un
proceso que algunas empresas verán
algunas principales empresas y muchos
comercios tuvieron que cerrar sus
puertas porque el negocio no es que no
les cerraba simplemente en la cuarentena
sino que ya hace varios años que viene
de manera negativa ahora le pregunto
entonces para dónde va el país se puede
recuperar fácilmente o esta tendencia va
a empeorar
bueno nosotros tratamos de ser
optimistas y entender que son todas
partes de ciclos después de un ciclo es
tan malo esperamos pero estamos
esperando que aparezca el ciclo positivo
la verdad que estamos tocando pisos la
economía argentina muy pocas veces
estuvo en esta situación y también en un
momento van a empezar a aparecer las
oportunidades y debes estar contando
porque se van las empresas sino porque
están viniendo estamos en un momento
difícil pero eso no quiere decir que la
argentina tenga que seguir por el mismo
camino en algún momento esto esto va a
cambiar es parte de las consecuencias de
malas gestiones por parte de los
gobiernos sin más de consecuencia de la
cuarentena pero bueno ahora estamos en
búsqueda de soluciones
ramiro gracias a por la información que
tengo usted un feliz resto de días